the sahara las vegas has done a major
renovation and it includes our city's
newest and most immersive ultra pool
rockies there live giving us a tour hey
rocky
hey you guys okay so of course if you're
gonna be at an ultra pool in vegas
whether you're in the main part of the
strip or you're on the north end of the
strip which is where it's at by the way
i've learned today for sure um you've
got to have food and beverage you can't
have ultrapool without food and beverage
right that is correct so right here
we're offering a full menu for our guest
some of the beverages showing pretty
much on the
right hand side right here we have the
mic dropper that we call it it's named
yes it's named right after the magic mic
live show here at sahara las vegas ooh
which we will get a sneak peek of in the
four o'clock show we're gonna go inside
and take a tour of their new theater
here at the tsar i'm excited for that
sorry what's what's the next drink well
the middle one it's our 32 ounce azilo
smash that we call it and of course the
picture uh we have our watermelon sugar
high oh
watermelon sugar high there you go i
love that okay and of course you guys
have gone under at the sahara a 150
million dollar renovation
what all have you
created here built here new so we're
still in the process um zillow was one
of the first venues to open part of this
150 million dollar renovation
we're currently working in
our restaurant row
one of the restaurants opening very soon
will be chickies and pizzas which will
be that's like the number one espn vote
at number one sports bar right yes on
the east coast and that will be probably
one
the only one here in the west coast so
we're super excited for that uh we have
more restaurants coming like um noodle
den um balos the italian restaurant and
of course working on some um other
concepts with food and beverage
department okay and really quick and
these just invite everybody down to the
north end to the sahara because people
are always on that side they need to
come over here yeah i mean there are a
lot of changes happening at the north
side of the street and we're very
excited for that you know with the
zillow i promise you next year we're
going to change every everyone's mind
all right here we go you heard it here
first i'll send it back to you guys
thank you rocky looks like so much fun
we're going to check back in with you
during the 4pm newscast